alina
is with us in cleveland ohio hi elena
how are you
hi dave i'm good how are you better than
i deserve what's up
so i just had a quick question i'm
making my debt snowball
and i'm currently
i have a list right now for everything
besides student loans and collections
now i'm currently still in school do i
pay off the student loans or do i go
towards the collection
since the student loans are in deferment
right now
how much longer do you have in school
alina
um if i continue two more years
if i stop and finish every pay
everything off would be
i would take a break for a year okay are
you cash flowing to what the rest of
your college experience right now
no that's why i was planning on stopping
to
bring it back to cash flow okay all
right
so there's a difference in paying
everything off while you're taking time
off to pay everything off
or taking time off because you can't
cash flow it yeah
which is it um i'm taking time off
because i can't cash flow and don't want
to get more
interested in debt okay okay and during
that time you're going to pile up money
to go back to school first
or you're going to get out of debt first
it would be paying off my debt and then
start saving for school gotcha
okay because if you quit school you're
going to activate these student loans
right right
all right how much debt do you have
total again
um total is about 28.
how old are you 23.
what are you studying yeah finances
and how much of the 28 is student loan
only 11. and what is in how much is in
collections
about seven okay what's that from
uh credit cards and
what they're called cash advance loans
and how long has it been since you paid
on those that are in collections
um majority of them are like a little
over a year
okay okay and what is the other ten
thousand dollars
um personal loans
uh my lease my
uh a credit card that's active at the
moment and
what else is it okay your lease yeah
yes what do you mean your lease
um the lease payment what do you like
at least a car okay what do you owe on
your car what's it take to pay the car
off
about a little less than 4 000 just
about four
so you're almost at the end of it yes
are you working right now i am how many
are you making
yeah yearly is about 34.
okay what do you do what do you do
at least i am in training to be an
accountant
okay okay so the student loans you're
not paying anything on those
collections you're not hardly paying
anything on it
so it's almost as if you're out of debt
now
in terms of what your monthly exposure
is so why can't you cash flow school
if you don't pay on the student loans
and you don't pay on collections right
now
because that's the majority of your debt
how much how much
how much does it cost you to go to
school a semester about
it's been about 3 000. well
give or take okay yeah 3k so you're
looking at
i mean well actually you still can do
that you still can do that
what's your monthly payment on this
lease
350. and it's going to be over in just a
few months right
correct now what are you going to do at
the end of that for a car
um i actually have a car that i did a
stupid decision and went for the lease
but i'm gonna go back to my
regular car there we go give up the
lease and it's paid for
and it's paid for yes okay yeah so we
get the call we get the lease paid off
we leave the collections in collections
you don't pay on the student loans
and you cash flow college and here's the
other thing and you don't have to quit
yeah and uh you cut up these credit
cards because you're just digging
yourself into a deeper hole that's a
good catch
all right so because we're talking about
these credit cards you say you still
have currently open
so you need to stop borrowing money
right now
well yes i'm that one getting paid off
next month
actually and it's getting closed out is
it is it cut up
yes you sure you sure yeah you just said
it was active
you could be honest with me well it's
open as active but it's not i don't
swipe it i can't
put up you did cut the card in half
literally
i sure did okay proud of you yeah there
you go yeah all right that's a good sign
all right here's what i want you to do i
want you to get in ramsey plus yes sir
we're going to pay for it for you and
that includes financial peace university
the every dollar premium map everything
you need to get through this kiddo
there's no reason for you to quit school
i want you to keep going yeah
but you're going to take an extra job
and you're going to have about one more
year
you're going to be real tired this year
yeah because you're going to work
all the time and go to school all the
time but here's what's going to happen
at the end of that year you're going to
have no current credit card debt you're
going to have no card debt
and you're going to have gotten rid of
the personal loans so the only debt that
you have you're not making payments on
and then you'll be able to cash flow
school originally does that make sense
it does and i think you can stay in
school and do every bit of this but
you're going to be working
a lot yeah that's 6 000 a year you can
do that alina
and honestly maybe even consider looking
at uber
and since you're online and you already
have two years into it uh maybe even
consider going online doing some
tutoring
so you can make up your own hours so it
doesn't get in the way of your education
process
but you can get the six thousand dollars
just from doing a side gig
yeah you can deliver pizzas and get that
yeah and so knock this stuff out get
that car gone
get that the credit card the active
credit card's gone leave the stuff
that's in collections
in collections the student loans are
still stagnant while you're
in school so you're not having a cash
flow there then all we got to come up
with is three grand a semester
and you can get that yeah and so it but
you're gonna have to be on a real
detailed plan and it's like an obsession
for you
yeah that i'm going to school with
adding no more debt and then when you
come out of school
you can address that remaining 18 000
very very quickly and you will know how
to do it because i'm going to teach you
how
anthony's going to teach you how in
financial peace university
with ramsey plus so i'm going to give
you a one-year membership
and you go through every detail of that
and you do everything i say to do
and if you do that you're gonna come out
and be going touchdown
yes you're gonna be going i freaking
want and don't go make up your own plan
ours works yeah all right so hold on
kelly i'll pick up and we're going to
get you signed up as a gift
and i don't want you to quit school i
want you to finish yeah
i'm proud of you you're you're you're a
neat young lady
and some people are probably asking
himself well how come dave didn't tell
her to stop
and pay off her debt because she's
already halfway there
that's three grand yes yeah she's not
going to an expensive school
no if she told me she was going to spend
50 000 a year
she's quitting right because there's no
way she's cash flowing that
right this is within reach yes and the
student loans can sit there that's what
they're designed to do for a student
absolutely and the collections they can
sit there too absolutely the longer they
sit there the more
pliable they'll get
only the only only only on the dave
rapture show but at the same time though
six thousand dollars a year that's
less than the average way less you know
that's average is ten thousand dollars a
year
yeah so she's in a good position to
going ahead and
cash flow that then her oh yeah kelly
give her
give her his debt-free degree book too
absolutely
to go with the ramsey plus package oh my
gosh i definitely notice that yeah
yeah you think about giving away your
book absolutely what's wrong with you go
ahead and give her destroy your student
loan debt so she can already already
read that as well
yeah just give her everything give her
everything so give
i'm sorry kelly kelly's looking at us
like what's going on so give her ramsey
plush
that free degree
kelly's about to cuss us out but i'm
with the boss so i'm good well that's uh
ain't nothing new about that open phones
at triple eight eight two five
five two two five here's the thing
how do you eat an elephant
a bite at a time with a freaking plan
yes you don't randomly run up and take a
chunk out of it
that's good you've got a plan and you
execute
step by step by step through that plan
and it will take you
into your future and then when somebody
asks you can say
i'm living the dream